hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
part two of the fastest Mac Mini in the
world series finally so if you like the
series idea if you want to see part
three soon given thumbs up to support
this series and without any further ado
let's go ahead and pick up where part 1
left off and that is with the install of
the fastest single SSD solution money
can buy without any further ado let's
just go ahead and jump right into this
so the 2011 a Mac Mini is interesting
it's too small for a PCI card SSD and in
terms of the Apple option actually
called Apple and nobody could tell me
there how fast their $500 200 50 60 a
SSD option was so we're taking matters
into our own hands here with the OCZ
vertex 3 max I ops Edition a blazing
fast SATA 3 base 6 gigabit per second
SSD that handles write speeds at around
500 megabytes per second and reads at
around five hundred and fifty megabytes
per second so we can tear this open and
check out what comes in the package from
OCZ and that includes this three and a
half inch metal tray to make this two
and a half inch SSD fit in larger
desktops but we won't be needing this
you also get this sweet sticker perfect
for the back of your car now or maybe
just slap it on the computer later and
you also get a user manual and the gold
itself it's the SSD and taking it out
the package you can see the form factor
is really beautifully simple just the
power and the SATA connector and the SSD
that's it looking like a bus ready to do
work in this Mac Mini now before the
install of the SSD itself we're going to
need a couple things we need a USB thumb
drive of 8 gigabytes or more and we'll
need to go into our fresh install of
Lion on the slow hard drive and download
and install the OS 10 Lion recovery tool
and install it onto the flash drive and
this is what we use to get that Lion on
to the new SSD now the links to all the
supplies needed to perform the surgery
are in the description below this video
right next to that like button and
that's where you'll find the mini
screwdriver set now I'm not going to
explain every detail in the hardware
swap process to get out the hard drive
and get in the SSD and that's mainly
because there is already a fantastic
step-by-step instructional video on
YouTube that I use
and followed to do this so that's in the
description but overall this entire
process was pretty painless took just
about 25 minutes for me to complete and
was actually pretty simple and I want to
say dummy proof but you know you just
have to have the right tools and you can
get it done just note that the screws
you'll be unscrewing are mostly really
tiny so be prepared to have a good place
to store them like in a bottle cap or
something well yeah it was altogether
pretty painless I've never opened up a
Mac Mini before so stuff was much more
crammed together than I'm used to when I
build regular tower computers but I do
have massive freaking gigantic hands as
you can see so that was probably the
most difficult part but sure enough 25
minutes after I started I was done and
it was time to fire up the new Mac Mini
for the first time now when you do turn
it back on hold down the option key on
the Apple keyboard and you'll get that
Disk Utility where you can format the
new SSD entirely in one partition for OS
10 and begin your install of a fresh new
copy of Lion that whole install took
about again 20 to 25 minutes and that
ladies and gentlemen is where part 2
finishes part 3 will pick up whoa this
part left off and you can expect to see
a ton of RAM throwing out this little
beast of a machine and many more things
done to make it the fastest Mac Mini in
the world thank you for watching and
I'll see you guys in the next one peace
[Music]